to reach the region hit hardest by the
earthquake you need to travel through
some of afghanistan's most challenging
terrain
a week on this long and arduous route is
still the only way much needed help can
get to this disrupted landscape
in this village in burmal district more
than 50 people were killed entire
families wiped out
muhammad roshan lost 18 members of his
family he wants the world to see what
little is left of his home
and
so far muhammad's managed to bury 17 of
his relatives
he's convinced one more body is still
trapped in the rubble
yeah
but
inside his new home a tent with the most
basic facilities lies his sister with a
broken leg it's a rarity women in these
tribal villages are allowed to speak out
but covering her face bibi hawa wants us
to know how she still hasn't had a visit
from a doctor
i'm in pain i can't walk she tells us
all but a few homes in this village have
been flattened the water supply cut off
lost six people from his family he like
everyone else is calling for help to
rebuild his home
seven-year-old mohammed has badly
damaged his leg and with the doctor here
for just a short time he needs treatment
the pain will eventually ease but the
grief of losing the rest of his family
will live with this boy forever
in the neighboring village of lawara
there is more stable continued support
international aid agencies have managed
to set up bases to assist those who've
lost everything
dr tafik was one of the first responders
on the ground
so we are taking patients with trauma so
we receive different type of trauma
fractures and
infected ones
the destruction in this district is
unimaginable and the problem now many
villages face are aftershocks and
landslides
over a week on from one of afghanistan's
deadliest earthquakes and this medical
hub is treating over a hundred people a
day they don't know how long they're
going to be here for
someday though the aid agencies will
pull out but leaving is not an option
for those who survived this earthquake
they face many months perhaps years
literally having to rebuild
their broken lives in zaman rashid sky
news burmal in afghanistan